so i've been looking over some of the
m1x macbook pro leaks from a couple of
months ago
and i discovered a gold mine of
information that i somehow didn't
properly understand
until today and based on what i just
realized
apple is gonna absolutely dominate the
market
starting this year and especially going
into 2022.
now if you saw my recent video on how
x86 is starting to die
you'll know that many of the largest pc
makers including
intel themselves are beginning to follow
in apple's footsteps
by ditching x86 chips and switching to
arm
and risk-based chips for laptops in an
attempt to compete
with apple's macbooks starting next year
but honestly
those other guys don't stand a chance at
least for the next couple of years
because apple is going to be doing
something that's absolutely
genius and totally unique something that
the other guys
can't copy so before i get deep into how
apple's gonna pull off their custom
m1x chiplets to dominate the market
i wanna explain the most important part
of apple's strategy
that they've already started
implementing with the very first
m1 chip surprisingly apple's very first
m1 max
didn't go up in price compared to the
previous intel models
which is pretty impressive considering
the massive differences in performance
efficiency and reliability so the
question
is how did apple pull it off well
the secret is mass manufacturing of the
m1 chip
which allowed apple to basically
subsidize the cost of the
actual macs themselves what i mean is
that when apple initially revealed the
m1 chip
alongside the m1 macbook air the macbook
pro and the mac mini
way back in november apple already knew
that they were planning on tossing that
m1 chip into not only the m1 imac
but also the m1 ipad pro that's five
of apple's products that they knew will
be selling in huge volumes
for the next couple of years especially
since i personally believe
that apple will continue to sell the
base 999
m1 macbook air even after the redesigned
m2 model comes out next year
so because of that apple knew that they
would need more m1 chips
than probably any other chip in apple's
history
which allowed them to order massive
amounts
of that m1 chip from the get-go from
their manufacturer tsmc
basically giving them a huge bulk order
discount and on top of that
apple is also saving a lot of money by
using the same
m1 chip for so many different products
compared to having to design
various sizes and versions of chips like
intel has been doing for many years like
their i3
i5 i7 i9
and many xeon chips making it
considerably more expensive to design
and manufacture all of them but apple
only had to design
a single chip which ended up saving cash
in various different areas
like labor for research labor for
designing the chip
labor for setting up the manufacturing
of everything from the silicon die
to the chip packaging process and much
more so in reality
apple knew how much cash they would save
by going this single m1 chip route
so much cash that apple probably could
have reduced the price
of each of these macs and still made
more profit than they made with the
previous intel max
and that's actually what they did with
the m1 mac mini
lowering the base price by a hundred
dollars and giving customers
a much more powerful mac especially in
terms of the graphics performance
so what's great for apple is that they
no longer have to pay intel
for their overpriced chips which is
awesome
but what people don't realize is that
the higher end
m1x and future max will save apple
even more money not only will they not
have to pay intel for the cpus
but apple will no longer have to pay amd
for their dedicated graphics chips like
in the 16-inch macbook pro
the 27-inch imac and especially the mac
pro
so keep that in mind while i get into
the main topic
of how apple is going to leverage
chiplet technology with the m1x chip
for their higher end max so let's get
right into it first off if you don't
know what chiplet technology is
tech qwiki explained it very well in
this video
but let me just give you a quick rundown
making much more powerful chips requires
more cores
which increases the physical die size of
the chip
that needs to be cut out of a silicon
wafer
but the problem with that is that the
manufacturing process
isn't perfect and sometimes a couple of
small sections of the die
could be defective rendering the entire
die
worthless leading to lost yields
compared to manufacturing
smaller less powerful chips which have
very high yields
so instead of making gargantuan chips
and risking the chance of losing them to
defects
amd started using chiplet technology
which essentially involved making a
bunch of small chips
and combining them together to make a
huge
chip package like in this example where
using chiplets would only cost
59 of the cost compared to building
one massive chip this obviously gave amd
a huge advantage compared to intel
the company that still uses the
traditional single huge chip process
and it's also a huge part of the reason
why amd
is doing so well today but just a couple
of months ago at
computex 2021 amd took it to the
next level by showing off their new 3d
chiplet technology where they can stack
dedicated
sram directly on top of their cpu cores
to greatly improve performance but
here's the most important part of that
amd announcement
we've worked closely over the last few
years with tsmc
on their 3d fabric technology to combine
chiplet packaging
with dye stacking to create a 3d triplet
architecture
for future high performance computing
products now what you just heard
is that the 3d fabric technology
actually belongs to tsmc
the same company that manufactures all
of apple's chips
and since we already know that apple is
by far tsmc's most important customer
it makes sense for tsmc to offer this
new 3d fabric technology to apple
and it makes sense for apple to utilize
it because
it truly is groundbreaking but now let's
get into how i know apple is going to be
utilizing it
and why it's going to make apple
dominate the market for the next couple
of years
a couple of months back mark german who
is by far the most reliable apple leaker
reported that apple is getting new
high-end macs ready
including the macbook pros the mac mini
the larger imac
and the mac pro but within that report
he gave us some very interesting details
in terms of the chips that apple will be
using for the macbook pros
there will be two chips codenamed jade c
chop and jade c die both with eight high
performance cores
two efficiency cores and either 16 or 32
graphic scores
so the only difference between the two
is the graphics
but here's what i only just now realized
jdc dye stands for the full die
with 32 gpu cores and jtc
chop means that apple will literally be
chopping off
16 of the graphics cores from the
full-size
chip to make a weaker chip which will
probably be going into the base model
16-inch macbook pro
as well as the 14 inch model this will
essentially allow apple
to mass manufacture a single m1x chip
to save a ton of cash while at the same
time
creating the illusion of a variety of
chip options
which will give apple the chance to
upsell chip
upgrades with better performance so for
example
the base 14 inch macbook pro could get a
binned 12 core gpu version of the jade c
chop with apple disabling up to four
potentially defective gpu cores
which is something apple is already
doing with the base m1 macbook air's
7 core gpu to give them better chip
yields
now on top of the base 14 inch model
apple could allow
you to upgrade to the 16 core jc
chop chip for maybe 150 dollars more
or maybe even spend 300 more to upgrade
to a
bend 24 or 28 core version
of the full size jade c die chip
and then for the 16 inch macbook pro
you'll get the 16 core jtc chop
at the base price with the option of
upgrading to the bend
24 or 28 core jt die and then of course
the ultimate 32 core version which will
only be available on the 16 inch macbook
pro
this will basically give apple the
ultimate variety of
chip options which will make it easier
for apple to upsell you
on better performing chips and not only
that
but apple is going to be saving immense
amounts of cash
by first of all mass producing just one
m1x chip and then of course they'll be
utilizing
chip binning so they can sell the chips
that have
defective cores instead of just tossing
them out and losing money
but now here's where the new chiplet 3d
fabric technology comes in
mark german reported that the new chips
will include up to
64 gigabytes of memory which means that
apple will be offering the new chips
with either 16 gigs
32 gigs or 64 gigs and the way they can
do this
is by using tsmc's 3d stacking
tech to place the different varieties of
ram on top of the actual cores
to save space and make it easier to
manufacture
and this is going to be very important
for the next step
in apple's master plan mark german
reported that apple
is redesigning the mac pro and giving it
new apple silicon chip
options either with 20 or 40
computing cores made up of either 16 or
32 high performance cores
either four or eight high efficiency
cores
and either 64 or 128 graphics cores
now you might be wondering why the heck
the desktop mac pro
needs eight efficiency cores and the
answer is that it really doesn't
but it's gonna save apple a ton of cash
and here's how
german says that these chips are
codenamed jade
twosie dye and jade foursie die
which literally means that apple will be
using chiplet technology
to combine either two or four of the
regular m1x
jade c die chips together to make
a huge chip package for the mac pro
so for the high end jade 4c die simply
take the 10 core
m1x and multiply it by 4 to give you
that 40 core
mac pro cpu chip and then take the m1x's
32 core gpu and multiply it by four
to give you the full 128 cores
and that's why it makes so much sense
for the mac pro's highest end
jade four cdi chip to have eight
efficiency cores
since it's literally gonna combine four
of the regular m1x chips together
which each contain two efficiency cores
but here's the absolutely genius part
about
all of this apple will essentially be
mass producing
insane amounts of that same exact m1x
jdc die chip to cover a wide variety of
macs
like the lower end 14 inch macbook pro
all the way up to a high
end 40 core mac pro and they could even
throw in
the 20 core jade 2c die into other
products like a new apple silicon imac
pro
or a very high-end mac mini if they
wanted to
and they're all going to be using a
single m1x chip design
saving them unspeakable amounts of cash
this level of mass manufacturing is
going to allow apple to subsidize their
max
and keep the prices impressively low for
how much power these new chips pack
making it very difficult for other pc
makers like qualcomm
to compete since they won't be able to
mass manufacture chips
like apple will be able to do and that
is how apple is going to be dominating
the pc market for the next couple of
years
especially in the laptop market the only
question remaining
is whether these chips will be called
the m1x or the m2x
especially since the apple silicon mac
pro isn't expected to come
until late in 2022 but either way
apple's gonna be killing it with this
chiplet technology
if you totally disagree with my thoughts
on this then go ahead and comment your
thoughts down below
but if you enjoyed this video click that
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one